fives and we get better together and
revolution revolution or evolution it's
a process of learning learning from
problems I in my opinion
I love mistakes I love problems because
I think all of that is part of the
process it's the way you learn I had a
ski instructor who talked Michael Jordan
how to ski and he said he was the most
unusual person because every time he
would make a mistake
he loved it and he realized that
mistakes and problems are part of that
process he was an ordinary basketball
player became the world's greatest
basketball player because he evolved he
allowed himself the appreciation from
mistakes knowing what you don't know is
even more important than knowing what
you know so our fears or a lack of
knowing and our ability to deal with
those those weaknesses and those issues
has been something that has helped us
over those years perform so we love to
revolutionize things we love to invent
it's part of our culture and so when you
say culture culture is a way of being
that lets you live out your values and
so we have a certain way of being and
behind that as certain principles in
case you're interested I thought it
would be interesting for those who care
to at the table when you're going out I
could give you our set of principles
we've established a set of principles by
which we agree to live by and their
logic is behind them that's what really
has made bridgewater successful living
by those principles in that kind of a
community part of this is independent
thinking we are in a zero-sum game so by
definition you can't be with the
consensus and add value because the
price if you the consensus is reflected
in the price you have to be able to
think independently and independent
thinking is something I think that I
worry about in terms of the industry
there are some fantastic people in the
industry you know they're just
hedge funds I don't actually know what a
hedge fund is hedge fund is a bully
avais of all different people doing all
different things but hedge funds on
average this is a great concern are not
doing enough independent thinking I'm
going to show you that there's something
about that in a minute the beauty of
being in the hedge fund business it's
the only business in the world that I
know of that is really not cyclically
dependent it's that your environment is
not your determinate you're free to do
whatever you want you there's no such
thing as a bad environment you can go
short you can go long you can take
spreads you can do anything you want
just as long as you do it prudently you
have the that sort of freedom so there's
no reason for us for the industry as a
whole to perform this way this is our
challenge this is the average
correlation the average correlation
between a hedge fund the hedge fund in
disease and the average portfolio stocks
and bonds is 76% why is that there's no
good reason anybody lost money last year
you can go short you can go long you
could take spreads if we as an industry
are going to be able to make a
contribution to the rest of the world in
terms of the the investment community we
have to do independent thinking to be
able to take uncorrelated positions
that's our responsibility too many
people in the hedge fund industry in my
opinion are just basically carrying
their beta through replicating innocence
certain return patterns we what we do is
we've replicated almost every style
there we've taken 14 different styles of
hedge funds and we've taken their return
series the average correlation is
between 50 and 60 percent of a manager
with that return style and we've been
able to replicate that return style just
creating just a passive mix for example
emerging market managers you could just
belong the emerging markets and and
whether they go up or down will derive
their returns so you need to have I
think
and more of an independent point of view
in order to create uncorrelated alphas
and uncorrelated alphas with what's
going to benefit the portfolio's not
replicating the betas strategies for
example trend-following strategies in
terms of commodities are strategies that
it could be replicated by simple moving
average of five date crossing the 20-day
moving average practically replicates
the performance of the average CTA for
example so what we're looking for I
think is I think we have to be able to
think more independently and I think we
have to think more about outside of our
experiences what happened in 2008 is is
really because the last prior ten years
rewarded certain type of behavior and it
were became the fashionable in thing to
do and that correlation built like that
you have to think of all about all the
different kinds of environments and the
correlations this replication this is
just our replication of the hedge fund
index which is shows a ninety-one
percent correlation those particular
strategies can be passively invested
they can be indexed so the in hedge fund
industry is going through a period of
time I think in which there's going to
have to be much greater differentiation
between managers and much more
independent thinking so as it brings to
the true asset class the the true
ability to bring through the true
talents let that seep through so I'm
taking probably too much time and I'm
probably lecturing too much but I just
wanted to share with you some of the
philosophy about Bridgewater a
definition of our culture and for me the
great satisfaction of being able to work
with people on the basis of that culture
clients and to be able to operate in
that way and I hope that the industry as
a whole will move more to the
uncorrelated hedge away some of that
beta and exaggerated that alpha so thank
you very much